the mathematicians alleged that God
created neutrons to keep positively
charged protons from repelling each
other the nucleus would otherwise blow
apart however deteriorating our two
isotopes of hydrogen hydrogen has one
proton and no neutrons deuterium has one
proton and one Neutron and tritium has
one proton and two neutrons if the
purpose of neutrons is to keep protons
apart why did God put neutrons in these
two hydrogen isotopes clearly the
quantum mathematicians prediction didn't
come true there should be no reason for
an atom to have more protons and
neutrons the periodic table of the
elements says something different ever
heavier elements have more neutrons than
protons for instance sodium has 11
protons and 12 neutrons rubidium 37 and
48 and cesium has 55 and 78 that's now
two predictions of the religion of
mathematics which didn't come true or
intriguing as we moved from left to
right on the periodic table
although the atoms have more protons and
neutrons they occupy smaller volumes for
example sodium has 23 protons and
neutrons and has been measured to have a
radius of 180 Pico meters chlorine has
35 protons and neutrons but measures
about half as much 100 Pico meters the
quantum mathematicians explained this
trend mathematically saying that the
radius of an atom is a function of
nuclear charge the higher the positive
charge in the nucleus the closer it will
attract the negative electrons buzzing
around it however potassium has 39
protons and neutrons and measures more
than twice that of chlorine that's now a
third prediction of mathematics that
didn't come true
let's propose two theories under the
rope hypothesis to address these
questions keep in mind what we are
trying to answer here we are trying to
answer two questions
why do heavier elements in the periodic
table have more neutrons and why does
atomic radius decrease from left to
right
despite that the elements have more
protons and neutrons under the rope
model of light and a thread version of
the atom an electron is a balloon that
encapsulates the proton star in contrast
a neutron is a crossroads of
electromagnetic ropes extending from all
atoms to all others heavier elements
have balloons encapsulating smaller
electron balloons and neutrons it is
inside stars like our Sun where chemical
elements are manufactured their
countless atoms and neutrons are packed
closely together as atoms are compressed
the electron shells merge and form
bigger balloons these larger volumes
necessarily incorporate more neutrons
for instance when the electron shell of
hydrogen expands it incorporates an
adjacent Neutron and becomes deuterium
if the shell expands again it now
incorporates a second Neutron and
becomes tritium the reason tritium is
unstable and radioactive is that the
balloon is stretched to the limit it
wishes nothing better than to contract
to a lower energy level to a more
manageable size by expelling a neutron
similarly uranium is radioactive and
unstable because it has 92 protons and
146 neutrons 238 nuclei it's compressed
into a volume no larger than sodium
which only has 23 therefore to invoke
the favorite word of mathematics again
the rope hypothesis predicts that larger
electron shell volumes will necessarily
incorporate more neutrons the larger the
electron balloon the more neutrons it
can incorporate within this larger
volume and the more the
outer shell is stretched the more
unstable and radioactive and animal tend
to be it will attempt to expel nuclei
--tz--
in order to understand why atoms are
smaller as we move from left to right on
the periodic table let's first look at
an analogy we have a box with four sets
of balloons representing orbitals of a
given chemical element if we squeeze a
fifth atom in the box each atom will
occupy a smaller volume the amount of
matter will be the same but each atom
will be denser this mechanism explains
how an atom shrinks but now why an atom
of sodium is larger than an atom of
chlorine in order for the analogy to
succeed the box itself must also
contract a star is a differentiated
object heavier chemical elements those
with more protons and neutrons are
manufactured closer to the center of a
star where the pressures are
increasingly greater not only is a given
layer compressed from the sides but also
from the layers mounted on top of it
Thunder thread theory it is this
increasing pressure as we go deeper into
a star that accounts for the smaller
sizes of heavier elements to recap the
larger and electron balloon the more
neutrons it will encapsulate and the
more unstable and radioactive a chemical
element will tend to be as the membrane
approaches its stretching limit the star
later compresses an atom like are
shrinking box squeezing the atoms to
their final sizes heavier chemical
elements those with more neutrons and
protons are manufactured at a deeper
level where the pressures in a star
greater thus despite having fewer
protons and neutrons sodium which is
created farther from the center has a
greater volume than chlorine which is
produced at a deeper level where the
pressures are greater the purpose of the
neutron is not that keep positive proton
marbles apart but is rather a direct
function of the radius of an atom
for decades the mathematicians have been
investigating the cosmic microwave
background radiation they alleged that
space is filled with particles they call
photons according to the religion of
mathematics when God created the
universe 13 billion years ago and beasts
of evil spirit the mathematicians call
radiation and it's now pervades and
haunts every region of space and
religion of mathematics space itself is
a medium a bag or an ocean of sorts that
is encapsulated and contoured by who
knows what the universe is therefore
expanding yesterday it was smaller than
it is today
space the mathematicians claim is
sizzling with supernatural and
surrealistic activity mathematics holds
that the vacuum is made of particles
which constantly come into and out of
existence the members of this religion
even claimed that they have experiments
to back their words thread theory
certainly regards the universe as an
amazing place but Mother Nature does not
run her shop with black magic again to
invoke the favorite word of mathematics
the Rope hypothesis predicts the cosmic
microwave background radiation all the
ropes extending to atoms through
neutrons filled the regions between
planets stars and gases it is this
so-called background radiation that our
technology now allows us to detect thus
because of their irrational insistence
on particles the mathematicians
erroneously concluded that the gravity
probe B gyroscope strikes space itself
around when in fact it is this vibrating
mesh of ropes and threads which forms
the background the mathematical world
confuses with space regarding the
mysterious appearance and disappearance
of particles that allegedly comprised
the vacuum the rope hypothesis proposes
a simpler and more down-to-earth Expo
nation the scholars are describing what
is known as beta and inverse beta decay
the ability for a neutron to
spontaneously convert into a proton
while expelling an electron from the
nucleus and vice-versa to become a
proton remember new a neutron has
neutral charge so what it does is it
emits an electron and I know you're
saying Sal you know that's crazy I
didn't even know neutrons had electrons
in um and all of that and and I agree
with you it is crazy and and one day
we'll study all of all of what exists
inside of the nucleus but let's just say
that there it can emit an electron and
by emitting an electron instead of being
neutral now it turns into a proton and
so this is called beta decay
what is physically happening when an
atom converts to a neutron or a neutron
to an atom how does the fact that an
atom loses its electron bead make it
lose charge and transforms the proton
into a neutral neutron under the thread
model of the atom a neutron merely has
to release one of the threads of each
rope that comprises it the resulting
architecture is an atom the release
threads now form a shell that
encompasses the proton star and both
begin to quantum jump and to generate
charge conversely the threads comprising
the electron shell of an atom can
spontaneously merge with the threads
comprising the protons star and form a
rope the atom has disappeared in its
place we have a convergence of ropes
each of which continues onward to some
atom as if nothing the seeming
appearance and disappearance of matter
from the nothingness of space is simply
the spontaneous conversion of atoms into
neutrons and neutrons back into atoms
the particle model proposed by the
religion of quantum mechanics has no
chance in science there are no quarks
neutrinos electrons muons photons gluons
gravitons soldat ons Cronin's phonons
or any of the other hundreds of
particles invented by the mathematicians
to plug holes into rational explanations
such a proposal would nevertheless make
William of Ockham very angry the alleged
traces of particles that the
mathematician see in their bubble and
cloud chambers in which they've never
filmed in the making are actually
electromagnetic ropes and threads which
they induce to come into view when they
shook the cosmic web the ropes and
threads that bind every atom in the
universe and mother nature's simple and
symmetric universe there are only atoms
interconnected by electromagnetic ropes
which intersect at Neutron
[Music]
in the coming videos we will apply the
rope hypothesis and a threat model of
the atom to the solar system in our
galaxy to get a glimpse of how mother
nature runs the mackerel
[Music]
[Music]